voilà tout ce que vous devez savoir sur
galaxy Z flip 5 de Samsung pour bien
l'utiliser fonctionnalités hack Asus
caché on y va ce que j'adore avec le
nouveau Galaxy Z flip 5 c'est qu'on a un
plus grand écran autant avant d'avoir un
écran qui était quand même plutôt sympa
ça fait augmenter par rapport à ce qu'on
avait avant mais pour autant il manquait
encore des choses avec le zflip 5 on
arrive vraiment sur un grand écran
utile qui sert vraiment pour le coup à
quelque chose qui permet d'aller
beaucoup plus loin donc ça c'est
vraiment super cool on passe quand même
d'un écran de 1,9 pouces un écran de 3,4
pouces alors vous allez voir que cet
écran de 3,4 pouces il est loin d'être
ridicule très joli dalle super un
molette que nous a fait Samsung ici et
si on regarde par rapport à ce qui est
sorti cette année bien 2023 c'est
l'année les plus grands écrans sur les
smartphones qui se plie format Z flic
c'est oppo qui a ouvert le bal avec son
finden de flip mais ils avaient un écran
vertical avec une partie sur le côté qui
servait globalement rien Motorola aussi
avec son Razer 40 ultra qui était
vraiment top qui est d'ailleurs toujours
vraiment top et qui eux par contre
occupe tous l'écran également au niveau
des parties caméras ce que ça me saoule
ne fait pas ça me saoule s'arrête juste
au dessus des caméras ce qui donne une
espèce de petite encoche petit creuser
en bas globalement ça va pas cette plus
belle effet c'est pas mal mais c'est pas
complètement parfait justement j'ai une
astuce si vous n'aimez pas cette espèce
de petit encoche petit creuser je sais
pas comment l'appeler qu'on va avoir en
bas sur galaxy Z flip 5 et bien vous
n'avez qu'à le prendre vous le retournez
et vous commencez à l'entre ouvrir vous
allez voir que ça date twister l'écran
va tourner et il va totalement
disparaître en fait c'est en
fonctionnalités Flex c'est le flex mode
lorsque vous le prenez que vous l'ouvrez
à 90 degrés que vous le posez comme un
petit chevalet et bien vous allez
pouvoir l'avoir dans cette espèce de
petit creuser sur le côté et si vous
voulez le tenir dans la pomme de votre
main il y a un côté qui est moyennement
pratique il faut prendre l'entreprise et
l'utiliser comme ça bon c'est loin
d'être parfait mais si vous aimez pas
c'est un petit hack qui pourrait
potentiellement vous aider et j'ai un
super bon plan vous pouvez essayer
gratuitement pendant deux mois votre
Galaxy Z flux 5 et votre Galaxy Z fold 5
grâce à next mobile qui vous permet de
louer votre smartphone au lieu de
l'acheter et pour lancement des deux
nouveaux smartphones pliable de Samsung
il vous offre les deux premiers mois
d'abonnement sans engagement ensuite
vous pourrez soit le rendre soit louer
votre galaxie Netflix 5 à seulement 52
euros 90 par mois ou votre Galaxy Z
folle de 5 à 79,90 € par mois dans
sachant que un Galaxy Z5 bien que ça
coûte 1899 euros des fois cette somme
est un petit peu dur à bien sortir donc
le louer ça peut aussi être une belle
alternative et avec next mobile vous
changez pour le modèle supérieur au bout
de 12 mois sans frais ni hausse de
mensualité vous passez par exemple du
zip 4 aux études 5 du Zulte 5 aux
Philippines 6 qui devrait sortir l'année
prochaine vous avez en plus une
tranquille et d'esprit avec l'assurance
vol et casse incluse surtout quand vous
sachez que le coup de réparation d'écran
peut monter jusqu'à 600 euros et ils ont
également un modèle éco-responsable
puisqu'il reconditionne les smartphones
qu'ils ont loué en neuf afin de leur
donner une nouvelle vie tout ça j'irai
en France en circuit court et vous avez
un code promo exclusif de 20 euros
valable sur
tout afin de découvrir et tester leurs
services et merci Alex mobile d'avoir
sponsorisé cette vidéo cet écran
d'accueil il est juste cool parce qu'il
peut afficher beaucoup plus de choses ça
n'existe des tonnes d'écran qu'on peut
venir choisir directement dans les
paramètres de votre Galaxy Zx5 vous
ouvrez le smartphone vous allez dans le
menu vous choisissez celui qui vous
plaît ce qui est cool c'est que vous
pouvez avoir un truc soit très épuré
avec juste quelque chose de très visuel
et les notifications qui s'affichent
soit aller beaucoup plus loin avoir
votre niveau de batterie la météo la
date l'heure bref avoir plein d'infos
sur cet écran d'accueil vous avez même
un raccourci pour lancer l'appareil
photo et petite astuce qui est super
cool lorsque vous voulez venir le
changer sans rentrer dans les paramètres
intérieurs et bien vous faites un appui
long sur votre écran d'accueil vous avez
donc avoir plein d'autres écrans que
vous allez pouvoir venir faire défiler
tous ceux qui sont préinstallés sur
votre smartphone comme ça vous changer
rapidement en fonction de vos humeurs et
de l'instant je trouve ça plutôt
chouette Samsung a aussi réfléchi en se
disant ok puisqu'on a un plus grand on
peut dire faire plus de choses donc
mettre plus de widgets donc apporter
plus de fonctionnalités à ce grand écran
vous allez avoir l'agenda qui est très
grand avec vos événements sur le côté la
météo avec des infos heure par heure des
alarmes votre nombre de pas des
raccourcis pour venir à passer des coups
de fil très rapidement et vous avez
également votre liste d'appels le
chronomètre à mal pour le sport le
minuteur parfait pour la cuisine ou vous
avez des raccourcis 10 15 et 30 minutes
maintenant audio également raccourci
vers smarting pour venir contrôler votre
maison avec tous vos appareils connectés
de Samsung si vous vous intéressez à la
Bourse vous avez le suivi des valeurs de
Google finance et des raccourcis vers
pas mal d'applications les messages
Netflix WhatsApp YouTube vous ouvrez
votre Smartphone vous allez dans votre
menu et vous choisissez ce que vous
voulez venir ajouter afficher en
fonction des besoins que vous avez vous
aussi les réorganiser très facilement
vous en votre doigt et en les faisant
glisser et puis bien évidemment il y en
a plein d'autres qui arriveront plus
tard Samsung travail avec plein de
marques donc ça devrait évoluer
d'ailleurs une fonctionnalité qui est
géniale vous pouvez utiliser Google Maps
avec votre smartphone fermé suivez votre
chemin en ayant votre smartphone au
creux de la paume de votre main ça c'est
idéal lorsque vous allez vous balader ça
vous évite d'avoir un grand smartphone
dans la main il est petit il est là
c'est pratique ça c'est cool et le truc
est très cool si vous pouvez regarder
des vidéos écran fermé vous ouvrez
YouTube vous naviguez vous choisissez
votre vidéo vous la regardez très
facilement la même chose avec Netflix
seul truc que je regrette ici c'est que
ils ont pas intégré de partenariat avec
Spotify parce que fait Motorola mais ce
que eux ne font pas donc vous n'allez
pas pouvoir avoir votre application
Spotify sur votre écran d'accueil ça
c'est quand même relativement ballot par
contre truc qui est quand même pas mal
c'est que vous avez le player Samsung
donc à minimum on aura quand même
quelques contrôles à noter que vous avez
non plus ni TikTok ni Instagram il va
falloir bosser là-dessus Samsung comme
je vous le disais vous avez plein de
widgets et bien il y a une façon de tous
les afficher très rapidement pour éviter
de les faire défiler les uns après les
autres si vous voulez aller à celui de
la fin 1 2 3 4 on avance non c'est relou
vous prenez votre smartphone avec
l'écran externe vous êtes sur l'écran
d'accueil et bien vous posez deux doigts
et vous venez les pincer ça vous
permettra d'afficher tous vos widgets
qui sont actifs et vous aurez plus qu'à
sélectionner celui que vous voulez pour
l'afficher et l'utiliser très facilement
ça c'est la force de l'os de Samsung
avec ici one you i5.1.1 comme on
commence à se rapprocher d'une
expérience de smartphone un peu
classique sur cet écran externe Samsung
est venu rajouter de nouvelles
fonctionnalités vous glissez votre doigt
du haut vers le bas et vous allez ouvrir
un menu avec plein de raccourcis vous
avez accès au wifi au Bluetooth le mode
avion la torche et plein d'autres encore
si vous souhaitez à gauche vers la
droite vous allez avoir toutes vos
notifications les SMS les appels les
compagnies et si vous regardez bien en
bas de l'écran dans cette espèce de
petit creusée et bien vous avez une
petite barre et bien lorsque vous
utilisez votre Smartphone vous êtes sur
vos widgets dans votre agenda et que
sais-je encore et bien vous n'avez qu'à
faire un petit swipe pop vers le haut et
vous retournez sur l'écran d'accueil
pour dire qu'ici l'expérience va quand
même vachement plus loin par rapport à
ce qu'on avait l'année dernière ils ont
aussi vachement bien bossé au niveau des
photos et vidéos c'était déjà mieux ce
qu'on avait les dernières sur les études
4 versus de cette équipe mais on voyait
globalement pas grand chose on avait un
petit aperçu c'était pas ouf là on se
voit beaucoup plus et beaucoup plus
confortable donc l'expérience est
vraiment améliorée ça c'est cool lorsque
vous êtes en mode photo sur l'écran
externe vous pouvez faire une photo avec
la pomme de votre main ça on le
connaissait déjà ça marchait sur les
smartphones de Samsung avant le petit
hack à venir connaitre ici et qui est
super important c'est que lorsque vous
l'avez face à vous les caméras sont en
bas donc globalement vous allez vous
voir sur le bas comme ça et vous allez
voir le trou de nez c'est pas terrible
que je vous recommande de faire c'est
prendre votre Smartphone vous le faites
pivoter vous le tournez vous mettez les
caméras vers le haut ça sera quand même
beaucoup mieux mieux vaut être
photographié par le haut que par le bas
globalement par le bas c'est pas votre
meilleur profil ce qui est super en plus
c'est qu'ils sont venus vraiment
réfléchir en termes de form vous pouvez
venir vous filmer au format vertical en
9/16 pour Tik Tok et Instagram par
exemple en 16/9 également plutôt pour le
format à YouTube mais également en carré
sur Instagram si vous voulez être dans
le fil d'actualité mettre une vidéo
format carré un par un vous pouvez le
faire et vous avez également le format
Full pourquoi pas autre petit hack que
je vous recommande vraiment de faire
lorsque vous voulez venir vous filmer
faire la vidéo en tenant votre
smartphone dans la main et bien c'est
d'activer la super stabilisation
pourquoi parce que lorsque vous tenez un
smartphone comme ça et que vous filmez
vous aurez une meilleure stabilisation
avec vos deux mains si vous le tenez à
une seule main comme ça et bien il se
peut que ça bouge davantage donc en
activant la super stabilisation vous
allez avoir la meilleure qualité
possible et d'ailleurs pour réussir vos
contenus photos et vidéos faites-le
vraiment avec le smartphone plié parce
que comme vous avez un grand écran ce
coup-ci vous voyez davantage les
meilleures caméras sont à l'extérieur
deux fois 12 mégapixels grand angle et
ultra grand-angle ça fait le taf on va
pas aussi loin que ce qu'on a sur la
gamme S de Samsung mais globalement ça
fait le taf donc on pourrait faire des
vrais selfies de qualité plein de photos
en mode portrait qui seront super cool
avec plein d'effets d'ailleurs qui sont
assez sympa studio mono LV mono faible
vous avez également le point de couleur
et l'autre mode qui coule et qu'on avait
déjà vu avant c'est le mode Flex le mode
Flex c'est lorsque vous prenez votre
Smartphone vous l'ouvrez à 90 degrés ça
va être temps pour plein d'applications
différentes et notamment le connaissait
en termes de photos et de vidéos je vous
recommande pas nécessairement
aujourd'hui de venir l'utiliser en mode
photo vidéo si vous voulez venir vous
filmer vous prendre en photo avec la
caméra intérieure caméra de 10
mégapixels ça sera pas la meilleure par
rapport aux deux qu'on aura à
l'extérieur donc vous voulez plier votre
smartphone à 90 degrés vous passez donc
en mode Flex et lorsque vous voulez
venir vous filmer vous utilisez l'écran
externe pour vous regarder ça sert de
trépiller en fait ce mode Flex et si par
contre vous voulez venir soit filmer
quelqu'un soit photographier quelqu'un
et bien vous utilisez le mode Flex vous
le posez c'est stabiliser ces pratiques
surtout vous activez l'écran externe
pour que la personne que vous shootez
elle puisse se voir ça lui permet de
voir si la pause est bonne si cadre est
beau c'est sourire et bright bref c'est
plutôt sympa et l'autre truc qui est
cool c'est qu'ils sont vraiment venu
améliorer la qualité des photos
notamment basse luminosité grâce au sein
de dragon 8 GN2 qui est très cool en
condition de faire le luminosité ça
c'est chouette et d'ailleurs petit hack
petite astuce le seul vrai usage que
vous allez avoir cette caméra intérieure
pixel c'est lorsque vous faites un col
sur zoom par exemple vous êtes en train
de faire un live et que vous avez besoin
de regarder votre chat et bien là vous
payez votre Smartphone vous mettez du
multitâche et en Avant Guingamp autre
astuce qui est très cool grâce à ce
grand écran pour venir taper vos SMS
directement vous avez un clavier AZERTY
alors vous allez voir que le clavier
prend beaucoup place sur l'écran externe
mais pour autant vous avez un confort
première taper dessus vous trouvez très
facilement vos touches donc ça c'est
chouette il y a un truc qui a changé par
rapport aux autres modèles c'est que la
charnière est différente on est une
charnière goutte d'eau permet de
vraiment levenir le coller de tous les
côtés lorsqu'il est fermé alors qu'avant
et bien vous aviez un petit jour au
niveau de la charnière sur le haut par
contre je vous le dis directement il y a
pas de changement au niveau de la
sensation de pliure on la sent quand
même mais on arrive à l'oublier en
venant l'utiliser régulièrement donc bon
pour moi c'est pas réellement un
problème en plus de ça cet écran
intérieur de 6,7 pouces dynamique à
molette 2x c'est super cool on y
regarder des films des séries autant te
regarder sur l'écran extérieur autant la
meilleure expérience se fera à
l'intérieur avec votre grand écran c'est
un super smartphone qui est disponible
en graphite lavande crème et verre d'eau
mais tout en sachant que vous avez des
couleurs exclusives sur Samsung.com je
vous mets un lien en bas dans la
description en jaune argent cobalt et en
vert le Galaxy Z flip 5 quand même 1199
euros en version 256 Go de stockage et
1339 euros en version 512 Go de stockage
mais soyez rassuré ce qui est cool c'est
que si vous voulez acheter au moment des
précommandes et bien Samsung va doubler
votre stockage donc vous aurez le 512 au
prix du 256 et en plus de ça il rajoute
100 euros de bonus reprises sur votre
ancien smartphone d'ailleurs allez voir
cette vidéo je tiens un coup d'oeil
parce que vous allez voir les dernières
technologies d'écran de Samsung qui vont
arriver dans vos smartphones plus tard
peut-être dans quelques années ça va
potentiellement changer la face de vos
smartphones et peut-être même des
galaxies Netflix allez savoir mais ne
vous inquiétez pas je vous tiendrai au
courant